e eu quero dividir com vocês uma
experiência que nós estamos obtendo com
pacientes internados em quarentena pelo
convite é o começar assim nós somos
alguns colegas do hospital moinhos de
vento que estamos trabalhando no projeto
para tentar entender os aspectos
emocionais que acontecem com a gente é o
que que é uma quarentena que que é um
isolamento
em quarentena não são 40 dias olha né
aparelho dela surgiu no século é mostrar
com 13 a propósito da peste negra
aparecimento dela foi em veneza e desde
então civil e a separação de pessoas
doentes de pessoas saudáveis trazia de
alguma forma uma melhora na sua pode de
vista epidemiológico acho que na época
não se tinha isso mas sabe cada vez mais
isso e é por isso que a 40 é mesmo e é
por isso que hoje as pessoas que sofrem
de alguma doença potencialmente
contaminante devem ficar separados dos o
que que a gente entende disco o que é
ficar separado o que que é ficar longe
uma morena comentou a vulnerabilidade em
que nos encontramos não agora mas nós
somos vulneráveis sem a
o imagina eu sou muito bem tô
trabalhando eu tô conversando essas
coisas que gosta de fazer e aí ela faz
começa a ficar um pouco mais cansada
estou mais cansada mas cansada a gente
tá sempre né você trabalha muito enfim
aparece uma dor de cabeça toma tylenol
dipirona e no outro dia um pouco pior
mas também a dor de cabeça enfim nunca
se valorizam muito o terceiro dia quando
a coisa fica um pouco mais grave quando
aparece dor no corpo aparece febre
porque deus obrigada a procurar uma
ajuda só essa vulnerabilidade para
rodízio a cor era só esse sentimento de
vulnerabilidade frente algo desconhecido
que se manifesta em nós através de
sintomas físicos da limpa
e o que é que nós vamos fazer coisas
vamos uma emergência mas a gente é de um
hospital e hoje as emergências são
diferenciadas vocês sabem existem
emergência só para pessoas com sintomas
respiratórios e vamos essa emergência
não conhecemos ninguém somos
repreendidos por pessoas totalmente
protegidas luva máscara acrílico no
rosto aventais contato conosco é mínimo
simplesmente para poder ver são
temperatura aí nos passam pronto para
que façamos exames de sangue e vamos
tomar tomografia bom aí o mundo acaba o
número desconhecido de uma tal é todo
mundo ninguém gosta de hoje a gente vai
fazer uma mesinha nascer e vai visita e
vai rolar
é mas enfim esse paciência pode ser eu
não é golo muito bem então sou obrigada
ficar no hospital segurar para o quarto
numa lendário também diferenciada e lá
nesse quarto eu estou estou
completamente solar é ninguém chega até
a minha porta não ser entra na minha no
meu quarto totalmente proteger eu não
consigo falar com a minha família não
ser pelo celular eu não tenho carinho eu
não tenho um abraço de ninguém eu eu
estou completamente sem controle sobre a
minha vida não tem isso gera uma série
de emoções eu fico deprimida eu fico
extremamente ansiosa porque eu não sei o
que que tá acontecendo pior eu não sei
que que vai acontecer será que eu vou
ficar bem será que eu não vou evoluir eu
não vou para o maroto em ir para uma
unidade de terapia intensiva
o que eu tenho que ser é nada porque
poder suportar uma ventilação mecânica
por dentro tá ligado a um ventilador
peão um aparelho que coloca ar para
dentro da gente que a gente não tá
conseguindo fazer isso sempre será que
eu vou evoluir desse jeito a minha
família
a minha e o dinheiro para pagar as
contas enfim tudo isso gera uma série é
desproporcional muitas vezes de emoções
antes da gente a gente começa a se ver
encurralar o a cirurgia frente a essas
circunstâncias que nós não temos nenhum
controle e não tendo nenhum controle a
gente parece tem controle sobre as
coisas e essa essa sensação que parece
nos dá uma segurança mas nesse momento a
gente não tem segurança como você sabe
que tem trabalhos interessantes fazendo
uma comparação com os prisioneiros de
uma cadeia claro que existe um pouco de
talvez o viés nisso mas prisioneiros de
uma cadeia com paciência estão não no
caso do corona porque você anterior o
negócio mas assim as sensações as
pessoas muitas vezes enfrentam e
o sofrimento essa sensação de
confinamento de raiva é assemelham o que
que nós pensamos então alcançamos
intentar proporcionar tentar usar alguns
recursos que nós conhecemos uma mensagem
para diminuir para minimizar um pouco
essa sensação de sofrimento essa
sensação de abandono a
é mas entendemos a medicina todos hoje
tendem a medicina dessa forma não não
não falou diferentes de nenhum lote nós
entendermos a medicina de uma forma mais
organismo para de polícia política eu
quero dizer a medicina em que eu não tô
interessada ou eu não estou preocupada
só com sintomas físicos sintomas físicos
acontecem em uma pessoa cada pessoa é
uma pessoa com as suas particularidades
os seus legados com as suas emoções
então é muito importante a gente poder
entender que nesse momento nós temos que
diferenciar canal nós não podemos só
ficar pensando você ocorrido vai ser
positivo você vai reagir o pcr não vai
não porque isso também agora ó existem
protocolos a todos os momentos surgindo
quais são os melhores remédios qual é o
melhor estratégia para diminuir o
impacto da doença
eu resolvi entendemos de uma outra forma
o que nós procuramos estamos fazer
produzir música e poesia para os
pacientes que estão internados em
quarentena nós fizemos e estamos fazendo
isso é um trabalho em andamento e
extremamente é muito bom é muito bacana
o que a gente tem tido de retorno embora
nós tínhamos iniciado o trabalho há
pouco tempo mas o filho de beth a
resposta que as pessoas têm dado cada
ver se eu mando uma música para ele e
ele sendo o meu telefone eles me mandam
pelo whatsapp a resposta uma poesia
é extremamente gratificante e uma coisa
assim é uma coisa tão simples é uma
coisa que nós pegamos assistindo
escolhemos cinco autores cinco poetas
infelizmente não me lembrei do thiago de
mello mas aí não brilhante poeta mas em
quem poesias que façam com que as
pessoas tenham vontade de viver poesias
que façam com que as pessoas entendam o
otimismo da vida compreendo e isso é
passageiro é que muitas vezes o que
parece que vai ficar para sempre não vai
aparecer essa situação dessa pandemia é
assim claro tá demorando um pouco mas
vai acontecer nós teremos vacina muitas
pessoas estão segurando felizmente a
minoria onde pelo menos no brasil que a
mostra que a gente tem é de 500 pessoas
estão buscando o melhor da mesma forma
música nós temos usada a música música
clássica
o palmeiras não é nada disso mas assim
músicas que possam contaminar a gente
dentro da gente e pensar não mas olha
que coisa mais bonita ouvir uma música
nesse momento é isso e isso significa
que eu vou sair daqui fica que eu vou
dizer melhores significa que eu vou
aprender com tudo que estava acontecendo
não é pensamento mágico não é isso que
nós queremos transmitir para ninguém o
que nós queremos é fazer com que haja
uma integração dos sintomas das pessoas
estão acometidas nesse caso por essa
situação grave dessa gripe com todas as
suas particularidades ajudando-as a quem
sabe fazer com que isso seja menos
sofrido e seja uma forma de ultrapassar
isso que de assim como uma correnteza de
um rio que vai passando e aquilo vai
passar
e sempre era isso que eu queria dividir
com vocês